We have a problem with transforming normals when using non-uniform scaling
matrices. If we tried to transform the normal with the same scaling matrix used
to transform the vertex coordinates, we ran into the strange situation of
normals getting bent away from their surfaces. How to solve this? I'll jump to
the punch line. What you want to use to transform normals is the transpose of
the inverse of the model matrix. You could also use the inverse of the transpose
of the model matrix. They're the same thing. Either way that's a mouthful and
let me explain. Let's look at how this solution applies to each different kind
of transform that we're used to. First of all, forget about translation
matrices. We're going to be transforming normals and translation matrices do not
affect vectors in any way. For rotation matrices, the transpose is the inverse.
The transpose of the inverse, in other words, would be the inverse of the
inverse. This is starting to sound a little like Alice in Wonderland. To be a
little more clear, if you take the transpose of the inverse of a rotation
matrix, you get the same rotation matrix back. This means that for matrix made
up of any series of translations and rotations you can use this same matrix to
transform points and normals. This is because the transpose is the inverse as
far as normals are concerned. Scaling makes it no longer true that the transpose
is the inverse so, we have to take special steps. If the scaling matrix is
uniform. In other words the shape of the object doesn't change. We can get away
with just normalizing the normals after transforming by the original model
matrix. For non-uniform scaling where the shape of the object does change we
must explicitly compute this special transpose of the inverse matrix in order to
transform normals correctly. Or you can do the inverse of the transpose. I'm not
going to explain here why the transpose of the inverse works. You likely don't
want me to talk about contravariant and covariant vectors. See the additional
course materials for more information. If you keep away from non-uniform scaling
matrices, you'll never run into this mismatch and can merely use the modeling
matrix for both position and vector transforms. If you never use scales of any
sort you won't even have to re-normalize your vectors. The good news is that if
you use scales of any sort in three.js it will correctly handle normal
transformation for you. It's only when you're using scales on your own that you
can get pretty weird shading results if you don't pay attention. And you do want
to pay attention. As while this is always the correct answer, it's costly to
compute all the time. I've seen many a young programmer led astray by normal
transformation. Seriously, back in the 1980s before any book ever mentioned it.
This problem was fairly common. Back then, we consulted for a hardware company,
who will rename nameless, writing programs using their expensive graphics
accelerator. And I mean expensive, something like $35,000, the price of a nice
BMW back then. I found that the graphics accelerator had this problem with
polygon display. Meaning we had to avoid using non-uniform scales as a modeling
operation. The company was more than a bit dismayed when they found out about
this problem, since it's costly to fix properly.